Never invest in a business you cannot understand.
Don't be a generalist.
Be a specialist.
Choose one or few fields you're interested in,...
...study every day to know what nobody knows about such field,...
...and say "no" to any other thing you don't understand.
If you can't take time to study any business,...
...don't ever invest in it because everyone is doing so.
For instance, don't invest in cryptocurrency because everyone is doing so,...
...if you can't take time to study cryptocurrency.
Don't invest in stock market if you can't take time to read ten good books about stocks.
Don't invest in real estate...
...if you can't take time to read at least five good books about real estate.
Send your money to only where your knowledge lies.